[Musique]
joseph sinimalé maire de saint paul et
cyrille melchior président du
département signé le pacte de solidarité
territoriale ce mardi en septembre une
signature particulière pour le président
qui est également deuxième adjoint à la
mairie de saint-paul est originaire de
la ville et bien pour moi c'est un grand
moment de venir ici signer ce pacte de
solidarité parce que je veux de la
population de saint paul je veux c'est à
dire continuer à servir la population de
saint paul et quand on a fait oeuvre de
solidarité après le pacte eh bien je
rends service à la population
en participant financement des
aménagements des actions sociales des
petites actions concrètes pour les
personnes âgées quoi les jeunes en
situation de l'association difficile et
aussi pour les personnes présentant des
handicaps
donc tout cela c'est l'action sociale le
lien social compétences premières du
département au service de la commune de
saint paul
une enveloppe de 5,4 millions d'euros a
été allouée au titre de l'investissement
à la commune et 625000 euros au titre du
social nous avons des grands enjeux
je suis à le territoire de la commune de
saint paul pour moi c'est une fierté de
signer ce
parc social territorial avec
avec le département pour une bonne
harmonie de la mise en oeuvre d'un
chercheur s'est ensuite déroulée la
présentation du projet de réhabilitation
de l'école fleurimont on à 68 écoles que
et sur la commune est elle son besoin
d'être réhabilités et on en a on a
besoin du conseil départemental pour
nous aider une journée qui s'est achevée
dans les locaux de la paix rer a été
présenté le dispositif du programme de
réussite éducative
[Musique]